[Music]
hi there its senior editor Kevin Bernard
on behalf of reviewer Nathan Minnie a to
tell you about don't starve for the
PlayStation 4 the laundry list of things
that can kill you when the eerie world
of don't starve is long and fascinating
despite the frustration that comes from
dying and losing everything and there's
a brutal survival simulation it's hard
to pull away
once the engrossing cycle of exploration
and crafting grabs hold as Wilson a
scientist turned survivalist you're
plunked down into this randomly
generated world and left to figure
everything out on your own outside of
some light questing the majority of your
time is spent simply surviving which is
no easy task the hands-off direction
paves the way for the world's grim vibe
and entrancing visual design to unfurl
with its own harrowing tales as you
struggle to stave off death every
resource creature and curiosity you
encounter poses a two-pronged question
how can I use this to my advantage and
will messing with it somehow result in
me getting killed considering many vital
resources can be perilous to acquire or
have an ill effect if used improperly
each choice you make at any given moment
has the potential to usher about your
own doom whether you scavenge berries or
kill and cook wildlife keeping a supply
of edibles on hand is vital you can
freely explore during the daytime but
nightfall ushers in a new threat get
caught in the dark for more than a few
seconds without a light source and the
darkness itself will consume you
spending too much time out in the dark
saps your mental health as well let it
deplete too far an imaginary nightmare
creatures spawn and attack you you never
truly feel safe don't starve smartly
entwines
all this danger in tension with a well
designed crafting system that provides
the real hook for risking life and limb
to push onward the raw materials you
harvest along your travels let you
cobble together crude implements to help
you survive which is your sole means of
gaining ground
you're pitched struggle some of the
underlying problems of the PC version of
don't starve waiter on the ps4 don't
starves roguelike aspect is utterly
grueling in the way it doles out
punishment while there are a few limited
means to prolong your life beyond the
grave most games that end with you dying
wipe out your progress completely this
leaves you agonizing over the numerous
hours you just spent chipping away to
gain a foothold your experience carries
over and goes towards unlocking new
characters with special perks to play as
so it's not a total loss but there's a
special kind of agony of having to grind
through from the beginning after getting
killed in a later game run if you're up
to the challenge and precariousness of
exploring the stark landscape bristling
with danger don't starve delivers
exhaustive depth and brutal punishments
in equal measure
it's grindy and frustrating at times but
it's also a beautifully grim experience
that controls nicely and packs an
absorbing punch
[Music]